Did you know that Whitebeard used to look
like this?
Or that Big Mom went from this happy little
child to eating her friends alive?
Or that Franky almost joined Gol D. Roger’s
crew as a kid?
Well today we’re gonna look at every single
backstory in One Piece.
Staring with the oldest character that we
know of, which is…this elephant?
Well, you see this is actually a highly intelligent
creature, the size of 4 Mount Everests, that
was already alive during the Void Century
and that was the companion of the legendary
character called Joy Boy.
The elephant’s name is Zunesha and what
we know for a fact is, that it committed such
a terrible crime, that as a punishment, it
has been ordered to walk the oceans for over
800 years, waiting for the return of Joy Boy.
Not only that, but during this extremely long
time, a race of human-like animals called
the Minks, ended up building an entire country
on its back.
And speaking of super old characters, we also
can’t wait to learn more about other mysterious
people from the void century LIKE Joy Boy,
who probably used to have Luffy’s legendary
devil fruit.
Or Oden’s Wife Toki, who time traveled to
the future…Or the secret king of the world
Imu, who seems to have been ruling from the
shadows for all this time.
In addition, characters like the Gorosei may
also be from this same time period as well,
so hopefully Oda has a giant backstory prepared
for us to explain the Void Century and all
of the people who lived and fought during
these lost 100 years.
And speaking of giant sized backstories we’re
moving on to these two giants, who are some
of the oldest characters in One Piece.
Dorry and Broggy are a crazy 160 years old.
Both of them grew up on the island of giants
called Elbaf and later formed their own crew
of giant warriors.
However, they started a really petty fight
over who had hunted the larger animal and
so when Luffy and the crew meet them, they’ve
actually been dueling for exactly 100 years.
Which created a lot of trouble for the rest
of their crew.
Because without their captains, the two giants
Oimo and Kashi, were later blackmailed by
the World Government into working for them,
with the government pretending to have captured
their friends.
And this guy here, called Hajrudin- he ended
up as a gladiator fighting for the entertainment
of others inside the arena on Dressrosa.
Even bigger and older than these giants, though,
was Oars.
While he lived 500 years ago, this ancient
giant was 159 at the time of his death.
He was a terrible villain called “the Continent
Puller.”
After ravaging lands across the world, he
froze to death in an icy Northern continent,
waiting for the day that Moria would dig him
up and revive him as a zombie.
However, Oars also has a descendant - Little
Oars Jr!
Little Oars Jr was an ally of Whitebeard and
helped during the Marineford War to free Ace
because Ace had once gifted him a Straw Hat
from the land of Wano.
The first straw hat we’re talking about
today, though, is the oldest onet: Brook.
This talking, singing skeleton has one of
the most tragic backstories in all of One
Piece.
His crew, the Rumbar Pirates, where friends
with a young whale named Laboon. Little Laboon
loved to hear Brook’s music, but when the
crew entered the Grand Line, they had to leave
Laboon behind, promising they’d meet again
one day.
After getting stuck in the Florian Triangle,
basically the One Piece version of the infamous
bermuda triangle, his entire crew slowly died
of starvation.
However, thanks to his Yomi Yomi no Mi, Brook
was revived after death and kept living as
a skeleton.
He was cursed to continue wandering the mists
of the Florian Triangle until he joined the
Straw Hats.
Thankfully even death couldn’t get rid of
that sweet sweet afro.
Up next is the former Fleet Admiral of the
Marines, Sengoku.
While he’s now carefree and living his best
life in retirement, we know from this childhood
drawing that Oda made that he was actually
very disciplined.
He can be seen here practicing his calligraphy,
preparing him for a long career of filing
paperwork for Garp.
On the other hand, this childhood drawing
of Monkey D. Garp gives a very different impression:
Garp is Luffy’s grandpa and we can definitely
see the resemblance to Luffy because Garp
absolutely looks more like a pirate as a kid.
This wild child would grow up to be the Hero
of the Marines.
He took down terrible criminals like Don Chinjao,
whose head he punched so hard it went from
being pointy to round.
Don Chinjao would never forgive him for ruining
his perfect spiky head and would try to carry
out the grudge against Garp’s grandson,
Luffy.
Garp also had a friendly rivalry with the
pirate king, Gol D. Roger.
This pair of frenemies teamed up at God Valley
to fight the Rocks pirates.
we don’t know anything about his past or
where he came from.
All we know, is that Rocks D. Xebec had collected
a crew of some of the most powerful pirates
in the world.
Legendary characters like Whitebeard.
Big Mom.
Kaidou.
Shiki. or Stussy.
With this crew of absolute monsters, Rocks’
ultimate goal was to destroy the Celestial
Dragons and become King of the World, but
in the end was defeated by Roger and Garp.
After the incident at God Valley, Garp became
known as the Hero of the Marines and Roger
would become pirate king.
Let’s talk about him for a second here.
Some things we know from Roger’s past are
that he originally owned Luffy’s Straw Hat
before passing it on to Shanks, who then in
turn passed it down to Luffy.
But most importantly, along with Kozuki Oden
and the rest of the his crew, he was the first
person to ever reach the final island and
find the One Piece.
Whatever this treasure was, it must have been
really funny, because Roger burst out laughing
when he found i.
And he decided to name this hidden island
“Laugh Tale.”
For some reason, he had arrived to the treasure
too early, and unfortunately he also had contracted
a deadly disease.
So he did everything in his power to ease
so the right person would be able to find
the island again.
After that Roger turned himself in to the
government and announced the existence of
the One Piece to the world, starting the great
pirate era as people scrambled to find Roger’s
treasure.
However before he died, Roger did one more
thing: He had fathered a son with a woman
named Portgas D. Rouge in secret.
Before his execution, he asked Garp to adopt
his son.
Even though Roger was a pirate and Garp was
a marine, he trusted his longtime rival more
than anyone to see to it that his son had
a chance to live his life despite being related
to a criminal.
Garp agreed to adopt that son, who would go
by the name of Ace and was raised as Luffy’s
brother.
But we’ll get to that in a bit.
First we got to back up a little though, because
we just skipped over some massive names: Let’s
talk about the members of the Rocks pirate
crew - 3 of whom would even go on to become
Emperors of the Sea.
I mean, just look at this picture of Whitebeard
as a kid.
Can you believe that he grew up to become
the world’s strongest man??
Not to mention he used to have a seriously
nice head of hair.
It seems that he never did have an actual
beard, though…
Whitebeard grew up on this island, that was
too poor to pay the insanely high taxes to
the world government and therefore had to
defend itself from pirates and bandits on
its own.
This turned Whitebeard into one of the most
powerful fighters in all of One Piece.
And his crew mate Charlotte Lin Lin was this
sweet little girl who didn’t know her own
strength.
Her parents abandoned her on Elbaf where her
hunger pangs lead to her absolutely bodying
some giants.
Little Hajrudin who we mentioned earlier was
even there as a kid!
Fortunately, Mother Carmel was there to raise
Lin Lin in her orphanage.
Unfortunately, Mother Carmel was a scam artist
who sold orphans to the World Government.
Double unfortunately, at the world’s worst
birthday party, Big Mom ate all of her friends
and Mother Carmel alive along with her devil
fruit, gaining her Soul-Soul powers.
After that, Big Mom built her food-related
empire, attracing numerous husbands along
the way.
Kaidou was another Rocks pirate with a seriously
messed up childhood.
Ever since he was a kid, he was used as a
human weapon due to his immense strength.
Then after a stint as a government test subject,
he found his way to the Rocks Pirates, where
Big Mom gave him his dragon devil fruit.
As a government test subject, he broke out
a fellow prisoner, Arbor, who he renamed as
King.
King is that last known member of the Lunarian
race, a mysterious race with black wings,
dark skin, light hair, and fire-related powers.
King is the one that taught Kaidou about the
myths surrounding Joyboy, which lead Kaidou
to want to set up his base of operations in
Wano.
Since the two were being experimented on in
Punk Hazard, this is likely where Kaidou first
encountered Queen as well, since Queen previously
worked with the other scientists of MADS.
Another notable Kaidou crewmate is Who’s
Who.
This member of the Flying Six used to be a
CP9 agent, until Shanks stole the Gomu Gomu
no Mi that he was responsible for guarding.
After this, Who’s Who was imprisoned by
the government but was eventually freed and
became a subordinate of Kaidou, hiding his
identity.
Later on, Kaidou would come to encounter Kozuki
Oden in Wano and have the fight of his life.
We mentioned Oden a bit earlier since he sailed
together with Roger to Laugh Tale, but we
have got to take a minute to talk about this
Giga Chad’s past.
After growing up as a trouble maker, Oden
was named the Daimyo of the lawless land of
Kuri by his father the Shogun of Wano Country.
There he gathered his 9 retainers, the Red
Scabbards - Kinemon, Denjiro, Kawamatsu, Ashura
Doji, Nekomamushi, Inuarashi, Kiku, Raizo,
and Kanjuro.
Along with them fought others, though, like
the bewitching Kunoichi Shinobu.
However, after a chance meeting with Whitebeard,
Oden went to sea to explore the world outside
of Wano.
While sailing, he met his wife Toki, a time
traveller from the Void Century and they had
their two children Momonosuke and Hiyori.
After swapping crews from Whitebeard to Roger,
he went to Laugh Tale and then finally returned
to Wano with the goal of opening its borders.
Unfortunately, in the time he’d been gone,
Orochi had pulled a power play with the backing
of Kaidou to gain power over Wano.
Orochi, was part of the Kurozumi clan, who
sought to take revenge on the Kozuki clan
for past conflicts.
He even went as far as installing Kanjuro,
another secret Kurozumi, among Oden’s retainers.
Finally, though, After a climactic battle,
Kaidou killed Oden while his retainers fled
to the future using Toki’s power.
This sealed Orochi’s position as the shogun
of Wano.
This led to terrible times on Wano for the
common people, like Tama.
However, during Luffy’s brother Ace’s
time on Wano, he met Tama and gave her hope
for the future.
While there, Ace also met Yamato, Kaidou’s
son, who was inspired to adopt the name of
Oden after seeing his bravery during his execution.
Despite being extremely supportive of Yamato’s
gender identity, Kaidou was otherwise a terrible
father figure, locking him in explosive handcuffs
and confining him to Onigashima for his entire
life.
But now we move from Wano to Egghead where
we finally met the eccentric scientist Dr.
Vegapunk - this genius was inspired to uncover
the secret knowledge of the world after his
friend and colleague Professor Clover was
killed at Ohara.
As the leader of MADS, he also used to work
with other scientists such as Vinsmoke Judge,
Caesar Clown, and Queen.
Of course, while Vegapunk secretly works with
the revolutionaries, he keeps up appearances
by making technology for the World Government.
So let’s talk about the marine Admirals.
We don’t know much about the pasts of the
original three admirals, but Oda has drawn
them all as children.
Boraslino appears to have always been just
as carefree as he is now.
Sakazuki looks to have had a very rough childhood
- I’m willing to bet that his absolute hatred
of pirates was inspired from a young age.
And Kuzan appears to have been extremely disgruntled…and
possibly a victim of childhood alcoholism??
Seriously, why is baby Aokiji carrying that
bottle around?
As for our other admirals, we don’t have
quite as much to go on.
We know that Fujitora blinded himself after
seeing terrible atrocities in the world, and
we’re super curious about what those atrocities
were.
Aramaki, however, is still a mystery.
And another mysterious character - indeed
one of the most mysterious in the whole series,
is Luffy’s father Dragon, the most wanted
man in the world and leader of the revolutionaries.
Recently in Dr. Vegapunk’s flashback, we
learned that the destruction of Ohara is what
inspired him to join together with Emporio
Ivankov and Bartholomew Kuma to form the Revolutionary
Army.
However, it’s still to be seen what traumatic
event caused Dragon to become an absentee
father.
It seems to be common in the One Piece world
that just throwing kids in the jungle is the
equivalent of daycare.
Of course, having the parent present isn’t
*always* a good thing…Like for Big Mom’s
many, many traumatized children.
At age 50, Perospero is the eldest son of
Big Mom, followed by the triplets Katakuri,
Oven, and Daifuku.
We don’t have full backstories on all of
the Charlotte Family - the most detail we
get is from Katakuri, Brulee, and Pudding.
Katakuri’s other siblings would make fun
of his huge donut-eating mouth, calling him
a “pelican eel.”
Why they went with this obscure deep-sea creature
instead of just calling him a pelican is a
mystery.
After Katakuri beat them up in response, his
brothers took their revenge out on Brulee,
scarring her face.
Afterward, Katakuri began covering up his
mouth.
In his mind, he was doing it to protect his
siblings as well as cultivating a serious
image.
Pudding, on the other hand, spent her entire
childhood being ridiculed for her third eye,
even being called hideous by her own mother.
The Charlottes are not what you would call
a loving and supportive family.
Now for the Shichibukai.
Gekko Moria.
Moria was once an idealistic young pirate
with his sights set on rising to the top of
the pirate world.
However, after challenging Kaidou, his entire
crew was mercilessly killed.
Him losing his entire crew is what would inspire
him to use a zombie army in the future - he
can’t lose his crew and relive that pain
if they’re already dead.
To replace his old crew, he gathered followers
like Hogback, a skilled surgeon with a twisted
reputation.
Hogback helped Moria stitch his zombies together,
including Cindry - who was a famous stage
actress in life that was resurrected as a
zombie by the mad scientist.
Absalom, another crew member, had his face
partially spliced with a lion, to better resemble
the predator he is.
As we can see from this drawing, though, Perona
has been goth since day one: it’s NOT just
a phase.
Bartholomew Kuma, another warlord we encountered
on Thriller Bark, was known as a tyrant and
served as the ruler of the Sorbet Kingdom.
Hes also Jewelrey Bonney’s father.
He was also a prominent member of the Revolutionary
Army, but was converted by Dr. Vegapunk into
a cyborg in service of the World Government.
Kuma’s was also used as the basis for the
Pacifista robots.
Crocodile was the first warlord that Luffy
defeated.
We can’t tell a whole lot about Crocodile’s
past, but we do know that he has a grudge
against Whitebeard.
In addition, we know he has a deep dark secret
that only Emporio Ivankov knows.
While working with Nico Robin, his organization
Baroque Works decided to try and steal the
throne of Alabasta while Crocodile secretly
sought the Ancient Weapon Pluton.
Crocodile
plotted against Nefertari Cobra, the beloved
ruler of the desert island Alabasta.
His daughter, Princess Vivi, is even an honorary
Straw Hat after their travels together.
As one of the original fourty kingdoms that
founded the World Government, the Nefertaris
regularly attend the Reverie.
As a child there, Vivi encountered Wapol,
the monarch of the Drum Kingdom, who showed
his true colors by slapping her while she
was a child.
In Alabasta, Vivi also grew up as a close
friend of Koza, who would eventually lead
the rebel army fueled by Crocodile’s lies
and deceit.
As children, Vivi joined Koza’s Suna Suna
Club.
These brave kids once actually saved Vivi’s
life from kidnappers.
Jinbe, the Knight of the Sea, and current
Straw Hat pirate got his start on the Sun
Pirates under Fisher Tiger.
Fisher Tiger was once enslaved by the Celestial
Dragons.
After his escape, he single handedly scaled
the red line back to Mariejois and released
the rest of the slaves there in a legendary
one man assault against the World Government’s
capital.
The sun pirates adopted a sun symbol brand
to cover up the Celestial Dragon’s brand
that they were marked with.
All members of the crew received a sun brand
so that people couldn’t differentiate who
was a former slave and who was not.
The Sun Pirates escorted a former slave, who
would grow up to be the Revolutionary, Koala
back home.
However, they were attacked by a squad of
marines and Fisher Tiger was shot.
Eventually, Fisher Tiger died, needing a blood
transfusion.
Due to his hatred of humans, he couldn’t
let himself receive blood from a human and
passed away.
Afterward Jinbe and Arlong fought for leadership
of the Sun Pirates.
Jinbe gained control of the crew, eventually
becoming a Shichibukai in order to better
the terms between the government and Fishman
Island.
Arlong, meanwhile, formed his own Arlong Pirates
and moved to the East Blue where he constructed
Arlong Park.
Not a lot is known about Dracule Mihawk’s
past, either.
We know he was a long time rival and friend
of Shanks, at least until Shanks lost his
arm.
We also know that before becoming a Shichibukai,
he was known as the Marine Hunter.
Another former warlord, Donquixote Doflamingo,
is a Celestial Dragon.
After his father left his position as a Celestial
Dragon, they moved to the sea only to be met
with hatred and persecution by the people
there.
Eventually Doflamingo killed his own father,
but it was too late to regain his position
in Mariejois.
After being taken in by Trebol, the young
Doflamingo began on his path to becoming an
infamous pirate.
Eventually, he claimed the Kingdom of Dressrosa,
the Donquixote family’s ancestral home,
as his own.
Before Doflamingo’s invasion, Dressrosa
was a peaceful kingdom led by the kind King
Riku.
Kyros, a legendary gladiator who became captain
of the royal guard even married King Riku’s
daughter and the two had their own daughter
together named Princess Rebecca.
The family lived happily until Doflamingo
used his string powers to manipulate Riku,
causing him to cut down his own citizens.
Kyros made a stand against the Donquixote
Pirates, but one of Doflamingo’s subordinates
named Sugar used her devil fruit power to
turn Kyros into a toy soldier.
A side effect of of this power was that everyone
forgot that Kyros had ever existed.
The toy soldier version of Kyros still helped
raise Rebecca, teaching her how to defend
herself as Riku and Rebecca were forced to
compete in Dressrosa’s Coliseum for their
own survival and the Donquixote family’s
entertainment.Another set of Oda’s drawings
from the SBS sections of the manga treat us
to some of the Donquixote family members as
children.
We can see that Trebol has always been disgusting
and also see a young Diamante, Pica, Lao G,
Machvise, Giolla, Gladius, and Monet.
Of course, the Donquixote Family member with
the most fleshed out backstory is noneother
than Senor Pink.
Senor Pink’s backstory came seemingly out
of nowhere, but managed to tug on fan’s
heart strings and is considered among the
best in the series.
Long ago, Senor Pink fell in love with a woman
named Russian.
Together, they had a child named Gimlet, but
all along, Russian didn’t know that her
husband was part of a crime family and a pirate.
Unfortunately, Gimlet passed away as an infant
from illness and afterward Russian learned
the truth behind Senor Pink - she ran away
but was caught in a landslide, causing her
to fall into a vegatative state.
Senor Pink would visit her each day in the
hospital, and one day put on Gimlet’s baby
bonnet while expressing grief over their son.
She reacted by smiling despite her coma, which
lead to Pink dressing more and more like a
baby to get a reaction from his beloved wife.
Senor Pink still dresses as a baby to this
day.
It’s just a hardboiled thing to do.
But while Doflamingo was a Celestial Dragon,
our next Shichibukai was a victim of the Celestial
Dragons.
Boa Hancock, the Empress of Amazon Lily, was
enslaved by the Celestial Dragons as a child
along with her sisters.
However, she was set free during Fisher Tiger’s
attack on Mariejois.
Hancock has also known Silvers Rayleigh for
a long time given that Rayleigh’s spouse
Shakky was the former empress of Amazon Lily.
Later on, she became a Shichibukai in order
to protect Amazon Lily from the government.
Blackbeard, or Marshall D. Teach, also had
a childhood as we can tell from this childhood
drawing from Oda.
We see him here crying under a crescent moon.
As a young boy, he was taken in by Whitebeard
and people quickly noticed his peculiar traits,
such as the fact that he never sleeps.
We still have a lot to learn about his past,
but since his ship’s name was the Saber
of Xebec, it’s clear that he was somehow
inspired by Rocks.
His crewmates are also notorious in their
own right.
We don’t know much about the pasts of Jesus
Burgess, Doc Q, or Van Auger, but Lafitte
was a former police officer - talk about a
crooked cop.
Blackbeard’s other crewmates were recruited
from Impel Down, which means that characters
like Catarina Devon, Vasco Shot, Sanjuan Wolf,
and Avalo Pizzaro all have lengthy criminal
records.
Shiryu, on the other hand, wasn’t just a
prisoner of Impel Down - he was a former jailer
who was so cruel to the inmates that they
had to imprison him as well.
As a child when the Whitebeard and Roger pirates
met, Blackbeard also met a young Shanks.
Shanks was found by Roger in a treasure chest
at God Valley and was then adopted by the
crew.
Shanks became a cabin boy along with Buggy
- both of whom would grow up to become Yonkou.
While aboard Roger’s ship, Buggy accidentally
consumed the Chop-Chop fruit, gaining his
devil fruit powers.
Before Roger’s execution, Shanks inherited
his captain’s Straw Hat and one day he would
give the hat to Luffy.
Some time after Roger’s death, Shanks stole
the Gomu Gomu no Mi from the marines, which
Luffy would eventually eat.
And now we move back to ancient history for
the oldest flashback chronologically in the
series so far where we learn about Kalgara
and Montblanc Noland.
Montblanc Noland, also known as Noland the
liar, was a famous explorer.
He befriended the dwarves of Green Bit, but
also traveled to Jaya where he met the Shandians
and saw the City of Gold.
While there, he befriended the Shandian Warrior
Kalgara.
He promised to return one day, but by the
time he returned, Shandora had been sent up
to Skypiea by the Knock-Up Stream, and Noland
was remembered by history as a great liar.
In the present day story, Skypiea would be
conquered by Eneru.
Strangely, Eneru and his crewmates were not
from Skypiea, but another Sky Island called
Birka.
After he gained his lightning powers, he destroyed
Birka without a second thought and eventually
wound up on Skypiea and declared himself as
God.
Mad Monk Urouge, another sky islander, is
one of the Supernovas.
We don’t know much about his backstory yet,
but we do have this drawing of him where he’s
sporting the traditional skypiean hairstyle.
We can only hope that when he returns to the
series, he brings this look back.
Capone Bege was known as a famous mafioso
in the West Blue before entering the Grand
Line - and according to this picture, he loved
playing with blocks as a kid - building the
castles that he would eventually become.
X-Drake had quite different ambitions.
He didn’t want to become a pirate - instead
he dreamed of becoming a marine, a dream that
would come true when he grew up to be a member
of SWORD.
Basil Hawkins, God rest his soul, got his
practice as a tarot card reader very early.
And Scratchmen Apoo got in plenty of piano
lessons before his teeth became a keyboard.
Taking a detour from the Supernovas, though,
we have our very own Cyborg Franky.
He was born with the name Cutty Flam, which
explains why he’d want to undergo a change
to the much cooler “Franky.”
He was abandoned by his pirate parents and
grew up on the island of shipwrights, Water
7.
As a young inventor, Franky constructed numerous
battleships he named “Battle Frankys.”
He and the future mayor, Iceburg, were raised
by the legendary shipwright Tom who constructed
Gol D. Roger’s ship, the Oro Jackson.
In fact, during Roger and Oden’s voyage,
they visited Tom and Oden even invited a young
Franky to join their crew.
However, Franky refused because he hated pirates
on account of having been abandoned by them.
Another parental figure to Franky was Kokoro,
a secret mermaid and secretary to Tom.
Later in his life, Tom was put on trial for
constructing the Oro Jackson.
To avoid execution, he agreed to build the
Sea Train for the government.
After construction was completed, in a plot
to acquire the blueprints to the Ancient Weapon
Pluton, CP9’s Spandam used Franky’s battleships
to stage an attack on Water 7.
Tom received the blame for the attack and
was sentenced to death.
In an effort to stop CP9, Franky hit Spandam’s
face with a rifle, permanently scarring him.
He also stood in the way of the Sea Train
in an effort to stop it from taking Tom to
Enies Lobby, which horribly wounded Franky.
However, Franky was able to rebuild himself
into the cyborg we know and love today.
Speaking of Spandam, though, he started in
the family espionage business early, following
in the footsteps of his father, Spandine.
He and the rest of the CP9 members from the
Enies Lobby arc are also pictured as kids.
Confusingly, Spandam’s pictured with a young
elephant, which is strange because Funkfreed
was a sword that ate an elephant fruit.
We can only guess that he received his unique
sword at a very young age.
The various CP9 members - Jabra, Kumadori,
Blueno, Fukuro, Kalifa, Kaku, and Lucci were
all trained as government spies and assassins
from childhood.
The one we know most about, of course, is
Rob Lucci.
Apparently, he’s known his pigeon Hattori
since he was very young, which begs the question:
how long do pigeons live in the One Piece
world?
Lucci was made famous in an operation he conducted
at the age of 13 where he mercilessly killed
500 soldier hostages along with the pirates
who were holding them.
This proved his savage brand of dark justice
to the World Government and made him one of
their deadliest assets.
Lucci is a fan favorite villain
And Hody Jones…is not.
Hody Jones was the captain of the New Fish-Man
pirates and served as the main antagonist
of the Fish-Man Island Arc.
He once served as a soldier in King Neptune’s
army, during Queen Orohime’s reign.
Queen Orohime was a ruler who promoted peace
between the races, despite the persecution
fishmen had faced at the hands of humans.
Her daughter, Shirahoshi, was revealed to
be Poseidon - a member of the Fishman royal
family with the power to command the Sea Kings.
Vander Decken, one of Hody Jones’ allies,
touched Shirahoshi as a child using his mark-mark
fruit power.
This allowed him to throw objects and weapons
at her from anywhere, which forced her to
live most of her life in isolation within
Ryugu Kingdom’s castle, protected from random
flying axes.
Due to his hatred of humans, Hody Jones assassinated
Queen Orohime to create conflict between between
the races.
Inspired by Arlong, he founded the New Fish-Man
pirates with the goal of taking over Fishman
Island and eventually waging war against humans
on the surface.
Using the power of the Energy Steroids from
the Tamate Bako Box treasure, he and his crew
mates gained incredible power that allowed
them to almost take over Fish Man Island.
They just didn’t count on those meddling
Straw Hats showing up.
Our next Straw Hat crew member is Nico Robin,
who like the rest of her crewmates has an
extremely tragic backstory.
Robin grew up on Ohara, the island of scholars.
Professor Clover and the other researchers
had uncovered the mysteries of the Void Century,
the Ancient Kingdom, and the language written
on the Poneglyphs - unbreakable blocks spread
around the world that carry forgotten historical
truths.
One day, a giant marine named Jaguar D. Saul
washed ashore and befriended Robin.
He warned her that the marines were coming
to attack Ohara to destroy and cover up the
knowledge that the scholars had uncovered.
Robin’s mother, Nico Olvia, also returned
to the island, but her, Professor Clover,
and all of the other residents of Ohara were
killed by the marines.
Admiral Aokiji allowed Robin to escape, making
her the sole survivor of the island.
In order to make a living, she ended up joining
with various pirates, eventually becoming
Sir Crocodile’s second in command.
She made it her goal to seek out the poneglyphs
and learn the truth behind the history of
the world.
Pedro, a jaguar mink who accompanied Luffy
to Whole Cake Island was once the captain
of the Nox pirates.
This group of minks made it their goal to
search for those same poneglyphs.
However, on a mission to Big Mom’s territory
many years ago, he and his comrade Zepo, who
is Bepo’s brother, were captured.
Zepo was killed, but Big Mom spared Pedro
after he tore out his own eye in exchange
for her sparing a few years of his life.
He did so because he wanted to be alive to
see the “Dawn of the World.”
Eustass Kid, a supernova and a chief rival
to Luffy, was born on a lawless island in
the South Blue.
Interestingly, his backstory was given to
us almost entirely through Oda’s SBS section
of the manga volumes.
On his island, there were four gang leaders,
two of whom were Kid and Killer.
Despite being rival gang leaders, the two
were great friends and also had a crush on
the same girl: Victoria.
However, when a criminal organization killed
Victoria, Kid and Killer united the gangs
of the island to take revenge.
Their alliance would eventually become the
Kid Pirates, ending with them setting sail
and entering the Grand Line.
During the time skip, Kid as well as his allies
Hawkins and Apoo even challenged Red-Haired
Shanks, which resulted in Kid losing an arm.
So that makes two one armed red-haired characters
in the series.
Trafalgar Law, a fellow supernova and chief
rival of Kid and Luffy, is the sole survivor
of an island in the North Blue called Flevance.
Flevance was known as the “White City”
due to its industry of mining Amber Lead.
However, exposure to this substance had horrible
consequences.
The terrible Amber Lead disease plagued the
people of Flevance and the World Government
murdered everyone who lived there as a way
of preventing the disease’s spread - and
what makes it even more tragic is that the
disease wasn’t even contagious.
Law only survived by hiding within a pile
of dead bodies that was being carted out of
the city.
After his escape from Flevance, Law joined
the Donquixote Pirates.
Surprisingly, Law wasn’t the only kid hanging
around Doflamingo.
He befriended two other crew members close
to his age - Baby 5 and Buffalo.
We don’t know much about Buffalo’s past,
but Baby 5 has her own sad backstory.
Baby 5 was abandoned by her mother who saw
her as useless.
It’s thought that she’s called Baby 5
because she was literally her mother’s 5th
baby - her mom didn’t even care enough about
her to give her an actual name: just a number.
To this day, she’s obsessed with serving
others and clings to anyone who shows her
the smallest bit of kindness.
Like many things in One Piece, it’s played
off as a joke, but is actual unsettling and
heartbreaking when you really think about
it.
However, Trafalgar Law had one person in his
life he was much closer to than the other
kids his age.
He befriended Doflamingo’s brother, Rocinante
or “Corazon” - who was a secret marine
plotting against his brother’s rise to power.
Knowing that Law’s Amber Lead disease could
be cured by a devil fruit called the Ope Ope
no Mi, Doflamingo made plans to steal the
fruit.
However, Doflamingo secretly wanted Law to
eat the fruit so that he could use its immortality
surgery power to grant Doflamingo eternal
life.
Corazon made a plan to steal the fruit for
Law first and succeeded, but at the cost of
his own life.
Law narrowly avoided being recaptured by the
Doflamingo pirates and eventually met Bepo,
Shachi, and Penguin, starting the Heart Pirates
with the goal of eventually taking down Doflamingo.
Cavendish, the captain of the Beautiful Pirates,
was an up and coming superstar in the pirate
world.
However, after the Worst Generation made their
debut, Straw Hat Luffy and his contemporaries
stole the spotlight causing Cavendish to hold
a grudge.
Funny, then, that he ended up in Luffy’s
Grand Fleet.
Cavendish is also possessed by a demon or
curse called Hakuba that takes over his body
when he falls asleep - still no word on how
he ended up with this affliction, but we can
guess it has something to do with his cursed
sword, Durandal.
Bartolomeo was another Corrida Coliseum contender,
who unlike Cavendish wants nothing more than
to be working under Luffy.
Ever since he saw Luffy’s failed execution
in Logue Town at the hands of Buggy, Bartolomeo
has been the number one Straw Hat super fan.
As head of the Barto Club, he’s collected
every bounty poster and followed every piece
of news throughout Luffy’s journey, forming
an entire pirate crew out of Straw Hat fans.
He competed in the Corrida Coliseum in order
to win the Mera-Mera no Mi back for Luffy
and ended up meeting his idols in the process.
Duval, the head of the Rosy Life Riders, was
born into terrible circumstances.
Namely, his face looked exactly like the Marines’
terrible Sanji drawing on this wanted poster.
Being mistaken for Black Leg Sanji led to
Duval living life on the run and constantly
wearing a helmet to hide his identity.
Thankfully, Sanji kicked his face into a new
handsome shape causing him to turn his life
around.
Jewelry Bonney is another one of the Supernova
who according to this childhood drawing has
always had a healthy appetite.
Bonney is also the princess of the Sorbet
Kingdom since she is Kuma’s daughter.
Ace and Sabo, Luffy’s adoptive brothers,
both grew up in the Goa Kingdom, but under
very different circumstances.
Ace was born the son of the Pirate King, but
to protect Ace, Monkey D. Garp raised him
as his own grandson and hid his true parentage.
Sabo, however, was the son of a noble who
longed for freedom outside of the niceties
of upper class life.
And one thing in Sabo’s life was even worse
to deal with than the unbearable customs of
nobility: his adopted brother Sterry, who
would eventually become the ruler of the Goa
Kingdom and who has one of the most punchable
faces in all of One Piece.
Ace and Sabo, along with their younger brother
Luffy, adventured in the jungles of their
home island and dreamed of setting sail as
pirates together.
But everything changed when a Celestial Dragon
was scheduled to visit the kingdom.
You see, the Goa Kingdom is home to an enormous
class divide.
The poor people of this society were forced
to live in a massive junkyard known as Gray
Terminal and lived off of the scraps of the
nobles.
In order to avoid letting the Celestial Dragon
lay eyes on these impoverished people, the
nobles conspired to burn the Gray Terminal
and all the people in it.
Sabo escaped Goa and set sail with the goal
of becoming a pirate, but his makeshift vessel
was shot down by the Celestial Dragons and
he was mortally wounded.
Thankfully, Monkey D. Dragon and his revolutionaries
happened to find the amnesiac Sabo.
Not knowing that Sabo was a brother of his
biological son, Luffy, Dragon raised him and
Sabo eventually became the second in command
of the revolutionary army.
Ace on the other hand grew up to become a
famous pirate in his own right, becoming Whitebeard’s
fourth division commander.
In fact, Whitebeard believed that Ace would
become the king of the pirates one day.
Unfortunately after Blackbeard killed one
of the fellow division commanders in order
to steal the darkness fruit, Ace set off in
pursuit, which would eventually result in
his defeat and capture.
Roronoa Zoro, the swordsman of the Straw Hat
crew, grew up in Shimotsuki Village and is
descended from the samurai that fled Wano
Country after Orochi’s takeover.
As a kid, he trained hard to overtake his
rival Kuina at swordsmanship.
However, after her death at a young age, he
swore that he would achieve their dream of
becoming the world’s strongest swordsman.
Sanji actually gets two backstories for the
price of one.
Originally as a prince of the Germa Kingdom,
he was the result of experimentation by his
father Vinsmoke Judge.
His siblings, who had been deprived of their
emotions, tormented him mercilessly.
Finally, after he was freed from the cruelty
of the Vinsmokes he found himself in the East
Blue.
While in the East Blue, he was working on
a ship as a cook.
He was endlessly teased for his dream of finding
the All Blue, a sea that brought together
fish from all parts of the world - a chef’s
dream.
The ship was attacked by pirates, but when
a terrible storm nearly drowned Sanji, the
pirate captain Zeff saved him.
Zeff saved Sanji because he’d overheard
his dream and also believed in the All Blue.
After the shipwreck, the pair were deserted
on a small island.
Zeff separated all the food they had into
two portions and divided the island in half
so that each of them could serve as a look
out in opposite directions.
Soon, Sanji’s rations were depleted and
he began to starve.
When he noticed that Zeff’s food bag was
still nearly full, he attempted to steal the
old man’s food, only to realize the bag
was full of treasure.
Zeff had given Sanji all of the food and had
only survived by eating his own leg.
Finally the two were rescued and they founded
Baratie, the floating restaurant.Nami and
her sister Nojiko were both found as babies
by a Marine named Bellemere.
They grew up peacefully in Cocoyasi Village,
but everything changed when Arlong decided
to make it his base of operations.
Arlong and his underlings Hatchan, Chew, and
Kuroobi had left the Sun Pirates to form their
own crew.
Arlong believed in Fishmen’s supremacy over
humans and built Arlong Park as his own twisted
parallel to Sabaody Park, a place where he
and his fellow fishmen were never allowed
to enter
as children.